[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com last night was the first of
many 20/20 democratic primaries in iowa
it is in fact a caucus system so much
anticipation finally the 2020 Democratic
primary gets going finally we are going
to have some information and data and
numbers about it is not just polls it is
now voting who takes the first win and
unfortunately it has turned into a
worldwide embarrassment headlines around
the world embarrassing for the
Democratic Party as multiple systems
apparently fell apart results simply
stopped being published after one or two
percent of the vote was out almost every
aspect of this has been a cartoonish
trainwreck and as of this recording we
do not know who won yesterday we were
streaming live yesterday beautiful live
stream we had six or six thousand or so
people watching the entire evening it
got to be 9:30 p.m. Eastern and we had
just a few results it got to be 10:00
p.m. Eastern 10:30 p.m. Eastern we got a
little bit more 11:00 p.m. nothing and
eventually just past 11:30 p.m. Eastern
Time on our stream we realized from
looking at what various DNC officials
were putting out on Twitter that the
results were unlikely to come out last
night and that was it for us for the
night and as of this morning we still do
not know who won yesterday's Iowa caucus
now it is normal that it can take a
little while once you have the final
vote to get the final numbers for what
are called state delegate equivalents
but we are talking about we don't even
have the final vote which is a
preliminary number used to sort of get
an estimate of what the state devil
state delegate equivalents are
ultimately going to be now
explanations that were being provided
have shifted the first explanation was
that the results were delayed because
the DNC is running them through quality
control that was already probably the
wrong lie to tell if an indeed was a lie
because that was interpreted by summers
we don't like the results and thus we
are delaying and seeing what we can do
to maybe change the results or wait for
results that the DNC is happier with to
come in so that they can release them
all at once and the were a lot of
people's minds went was this is meant to
hurt Bernie in some way shape or form
but it actually doesn't appear to be the
case it appears that that was merely a
cover again this is what we believe as
of right now it appears that the quality
control talking point was a cover for
what was a total breakdown and failure
of a technological system an IT
internet-based app software system that
was used to tally and report the results
of the Iowa caucus by the time you hear
this by the time you watch today's show
you may know the results you may have a
clearer explanation as to what exactly
happened last night the DNC is saying
that the results are going to be
released sometime today now in the wake
of this multiple candidates have claimed
to either have internal numbers showing
that they won or gave speeches making it
sound like they won in fact Amy
Klobuchar did something hilarious last
night at around 11:15 I think it was
11:00 11:15 p.m. Eastern time we had no
results Amy Klobuchar was in like fourth
or fifth place based on like two percent
of the vote at that time she came out
and gave a speech that seemed like a
victory speech even though she hadn't
she certainly wasn't in the lead and it
she certainly hadn't we didn't have
enough information to know whether
anyone had won she kind of gave a
victory speech which in a way was genius
because nothing was going on everything
was stopped and a whole bunch of
networks ended up covering the Klobuchar
speech even though she was like in
fourth or fifth place with about 10
percent of the vote at the time then you
had people judge he Pete Buddha jej
words that was the early leader
yesterday he put out a statement kind of
like implying he won he says Iowa you
have shocked the nation I guess the real
shock was how in
competent the process was but Pete
Buddha judge with his comment suggesting
I guess that it was shocking that he was
doing so well at least in the early
numbers then Bernie Sanders Bernie
Sanders says that Bernie has his own
internal polling saying he got 29
percent of the vote Buddha judge 24
percent warned 21 with Joe Biden in a
distant fourth at 12 percent and we'll
talk about the Biden thing in a second
this is all now being compounded by the
claim that the unreleased Des Moines
Register poll from the weekend had these
results which were Bernie first Biden
forth yesterday I told you that over the
weekend the Des Moines Register decided
not to release their last poll before
voting because of a claim that had been
made that someone who was interviewed
for the poll said when they asked me the
question about who I support and they
read me the list of candidates they
didn't read every candidate and that of
course is a really big deal when you
were doing polling so the Des Moines
Register on that basis said they were
canceling the release of the poll that
however the the claim now is from 538
that it was in that unreleased poll
Bernie 22 wore in 18 be dead judge 16
and Biden 13 and that is very similar to
what Bernie's internal polling is
showing if these results or some version
of them are accurate this is a potential
game-changer for Joe Biden Joe Biden in
a sense had the most to lose last night
because as the longtime presumptive
frontrunner even though he was polling a
close second in Iowa going in yesterday
if Biden ends up with half of the
support that polling showed this is
extraordinarily damaging to Joe Biden
and if that's the case I wouldn't be
surprised to see the DNC establishment
rapidly shift likely to Pete Budaj edge
you would think maybe they would go to
Klobuchar but Khloe shard that even
worse than Joe Biden yesterday based
just on those early results that we had
we'll see what the final numbers show
and that could be a disaster for Joe
Biden but then if you zoom out a little
bit
and this is really the tragedy this is a
fiasco that plays directly into Donald
Trump's hands who immediately started
making fun of the whole process on
Twitter it's a great effect and why
wouldn't he the process became a
complete and total farce Trump tweeting
about how a coin toss is used to decide
who gets a last delegate within a
particular precinct and that's true
that's part of the process check out
this video of a coin toss happening
yesterday in the end these single
delegates decided by a coin toss make
very little difference but it looks
really silly when people are voting and
then you flip a coin it's crazy
Trump then tweeting quote the Democrat
caucus is an unmitigated disaster
nothing works
just like they ran the country remember
the five billion dollar Obamacare
website that should have cost two
percent of that the only person that can
claim a very big victory in Iowa last
night is Trump and you know what guys
he's right
unfortunately this gives a ton of
visibility for their keep government out
of stuff ideology now in reality the
issue here is the DNC not the government
but it doesn't matter and case in point
Trump retweeting a guy I know guy Benson
who posted no but seriously let us run
your health care they said now it's a
complete wrong reaction to last night's
fiasco the DNC wouldn't be running
health care but still this stuff works
the Fiasco plays directly into
everything that they are arguing and
have been doing for years at this point
in time and the way in which this might
again mess up the credibility of the
entire primary process is raining once
again and I'll explain what I mean by
that imagine that Joe Biden is expecting
to come in first or second based on the
polling and he ends up fourth or fifth
as he might end up
based on the early results we have after
this fiasco with a delay for quality
control followed by we just don't have
any results we'll get them to you
hopefully sometime tomorrow your Joe
Biden you were polling first second and
you want and you end up coming in fourth
fifth you immediately say I don't
believe these results I don't believe
these results can be trusted and you
either say foul play or just errors or
whatever the case may be and then you
immediately have a disastrous situation
where the presumptive frontrunner at
least for a long time right is publicly
saying I don't trust our own results in
this primary caucus it's a disaster
it's an unmet to quote Trump it is an
unmitigated disaster for Democrats it
will further divide Democrats it will
help Donald Trump even more it's truly
sickening and it allows Trump and the
right it allows anyone who wants to make
the case that Democrats are incapable of
governing to make it on the basis that
they can't even get a caucus right now I
know that in the end there will probably
be explanations that go back to you know
it was whoever the technology was
outsourced to that dropped the ball and
they're offering a refund for what they
charge to make this app it doesn't
matter what matters is story and
narrative and that is the story right
now I'm curious whether tonight Donald
Trump will take advantage of this fiasco
in the State of the Union speech which
we will carry live on YouTube twitch and
Facebook starting at 8:30 the speeches
at 9:00 p.m.
join me early at 8:30 p.m. Eastern Time
I hope you'll join I have published
tonight's State of the Union bingo card
to my Twitter page at D Pakman you can
download it and play along we'll see who
uh who ends up with bingo tonight let's
talk about John Bolton briefly there are
multiple new reports out that Donald
Trump is keeping a list of people who
crossed him during his presidency who he
would like to get locked up eventually
and his own former national security
adviser John Bolton is reportedly on
that list we heard this from Rick Wilson
we've had Rick on the show longtime
Republican strategist he's an anti Trump
Republic
he says that Donald Trump is likely to
start putting pressure on the Justice
Department to try to get revenge on
people like Bolton Bolton of course
recently saying that in his upcoming
book in the manuscript portion that was
released says that Donald Trump
personally told him withhold the Ukraine
aid until Ukraine smears Joe Biden
publicly of course the Senate is
expected to vote to acquit Donald Trump
tomorrow Wednesday in the Senate Rick
Wilson says that John Bolton has one
choice right now and that John Bolton
must leak the full manuscript of the
book today
the reason Wilson says this is that if
Bolton doesn't leak the full transcript
with additional context and assertions
related to what Trump told him about
Ukraine Trump gets acquitted tomorrow
and then ruins Bolton's life Wilson says
Bolton's only shot is to try to get the
full story out today of what he saw
Trump do get it into the public before
the Senate votes to make the vote look
like a sham kangaroo court vote which of
course is exactly what that vote will be
investigative reporter Gabriel Sherman
says it's not just Bolton on Trump's
enemies list it's Republicans and
Democrats Adam Schiff is on Trump's list
Jerry Nadler is on Trump's list even
Republican senator Mitt Romney from Utah
is reportedly on that list I can imagine
this list of enemies written in crayon
on a napkin from Kentucky Fried Chicken
that Trump was eating on Air Force One
but it doesn't matter because this is a
dystopian reality Sherman reports that
he was told Trump wants John Bolton
criminally investigated one possibility
would be for the mishandling of
classified information that Trump seems
to think John Bolton was engaged in
which is truly even a crew call the pot
pot calling the kettle black when you
were donald trump talking about miss
handling sensitive information there's
another report that trump wants to leak
emails showing that bolton was doing pay
to play while on the national security
council that's been denied by people
close to bolton if this happens the
transition to full-blown authoritarian
dictatorship will be complete the
attempted jailing of former elected
and of administration officials on
trumped-up charges as directed by the
president now this is a good opportunity
to clarify something we need elected
officials held more accountable than
they are held I have no problem with
elected officials current and former
being investigated as part of a fair
judicial process we lack that we have
this de facto immunity that so many of
our elected officials and our elites
have merely because they are in a
position of power but you don't do it by
having the president make a list of
enemies that wants that he wants revenge
on and then forcing the Justice
Department to investigate them this is
exactly why though I'm saying
there have been no consequences for
Donald Trump's actions so why wouldn't
he do this Russia probe possible
cognitive decline hush money payments
campaign finance violations hiding his
taxes emoluments violations and he's
fine
he's continuing to be president he's
making the u.s. a laughingstock why
wouldn't he be emboldened by that and
say hey let me make a list of enemies
and I'll try to get them jailed sometime
soon because he's gotten away with
everything so far
and unless we vote him out on November
3rd he will likely succeed at triggering
at least some investigation of his
political enemies he will get away with
all of it as far as john bolton i hope
it's clear to him he has one choice it's
not even really a choice when there's
only one he has to spill the beans
period as far as love Parnas I hope he
publishes everything he has including
every video he has access to but in the
meantime this authoritarian nightmare
has to be stopped one way or the other
and there's really no the other right
now the one way is vote him out
overwhelmingly on November 3rd because
nothing else is having any effect let me
know what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman make sure you're following me
there the david pakman show at David
Pakman
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com all right today's new members
of the day are Brian Smith and Tommy
Bush I was in a band with Tommy in
Brooklyn when I lived there so great to
see both of these names as today's new
members of the day also want to say
thanks to today's longtime sustaining
member of the day Frank traffic hunt who
has been with us almost five years join
up today it's cheap it's easy
it feels good man join pakman.com I have
to tell you Michael Bloomberg is doing
something absolutely hilarious because
it shows how easily trigger able Donald
Trump is Michael Bloomberg is trolling
Donald Trump about his weight remember
that this is something Trump is very
triggering about by all serious accounts
Donald Trump is clinically obese now he
officially claims to be 6 foot 3 inches
tall and weigh 239 pounds if true that
puts him like a pound below clinically
obese but nobody believes that height
Trump is pictured in net in a number of
pictures he's standing next to people
known to be shorter than 6-3 and Trump
is very clearly shorter than them so we
know this is a very sensitive topic for
Donald Trump the alpha male this is an
ad that Michael Bloomberg put together
where he specifically uses what are
known as fat pics of Donald Trump
playing golf now I'm not calling them
fat pics pejoratively these are specific
pictures of Donald Trump playing golf
and like an all-white very light khakis
and a white shirt where he is known to
be absolutely furious when these
pictures are used because okay he looks
extremely large in them and Trump
doesn't like looking this way check it
out it even includes a picture of Trump
looking visibly exhausted and sort of
climbing to reach what looks like an
errant golf ball that he shot off the
course take a look
people have said when you were mayor the
city gave Trump a contract to operate a
golf course
yes that's true but he was the only
bidder and running a golf course is the
only job that I would hire them for I'm
Mike Bloomberg and I approve this
message
it is now being reported by Charlie
Gasperi no no left-wing bomb thrower
he's a reporter for box Fox Business
Network that the Bloomberg ads with the
so-called fat pics have made Trump
furious and that he's been melting down
privately and also tweeting endlessly
about Michael Bloomberg who he has
dubbed mini Mike Trump tweeting in close
succession quote mini Mike is part of
the fake news they are all working
together in fact Bloomberg isn't
covering himself to boring to do or
other Dems only Trump that sounds fair
it's all the fake news media and that's
why nobody believes in them anymore
continuing to focus on mini mike saying
quote many of the ads you were watching
were paid for by mini mike bloomberg he
is going nowhere just wasting his money
but he is getting the DNC to rig the
election against crazy Bernie something
they wouldn't do for Cory Booker and
others they are going to do it again to
Bernie 2016 and then once again and this
one is actually hilarious Trump tweeting
so triggered mini Mike is now
negotiating both to get on the Democrat
primary debate stage and to have the
right to stand on boxes or a lift during
the debates this is sometimes but not
really fair that is absolutely hilarious
the stuff Trump comes up with when he
gets triggered is so funny he also did
something Trump did that he rarely does
if ever which is he tweeted about
exercising now remember Donald Trump is
the guy who believes that when the human
body exercises it depletes some total
amount of energy that you have at your
disposal for life and so he's not a guy
who brags about exercising and yet after
the fat pick ad came out Donald Trump
tweeting a picture of himself golfing
with a caption getting a little exercise
this morning so regardless of
Bloomberg's chances and the chances
aren't great although I do believe it's
possible Mike Bloomberg could end up
third in delegates one if he continues
the strategy
that we've outlined a couple of weeks
ago this is just fantastic I would love
to see Bloomberg also do some ads that
are compilations of Trump's slurred
speech you know the United States of
America god bless the USA the Israeli
city of faroush ylim and that that type
of thing whoever is doing these knows
exactly what the trigger points are for
Donald Trump and is exploiting them I
saw that the Bloomberg campaign is
hiring some data science people here in
Massachusetts probably another Super
Tuesday States as well clearly Bloomberg
is not being shy about laying out the
cash and we can expect a lot of action
from Bloomberg I just hope there's more
of these ads that are triggering Trump
visibly on Twitter last thing to clarify
I'm not making fun of obesity nor do I
find it funny it's a serious medical
condition what I'm pointing out is that
the supposed alpha male Trump who's the
best at everything
both eats a terrible diet doesn't
exercise and is so easily trigger Abul
when you hit certain pressure points and
Michael Bloomberg is taking advantage of
those okay I've been thinking about
whether or not to do this story and it
just has to be done all right Joe Biden
is really weird about touching voters
I'm not talking about the creepy Uncle
Joe stuff related to women okay I'm
talking about something totally
different here I'm talking about how Joe
Biden gets very strange in even remotely
contentious conversations with men who
ask him questions on the campaign trail
now I'm gonna show you two videos of
this normal caveat if Biden's the
nominee I'm voting for Biden this is not
about anything other than this is
strange
I'd be a hypocrite if I didn't point
this out since I point out strange
behavior by other candidates I talked
about this in a recent livestream and I
pointed out Joe's behavior is oddly
aggressive towards voters and some
people immediately said David Joe's not
aggressive you're just a beta male and
you're uncomfortable with confrontation
first of all this has nothing to do with
me and I encourage you to look at these
videos if you're listening to the
podcast or on the radio find the visual
component we're going to play and tell
me
this is normal behavior if you normally
behave this way with people around you
in your real real life I want to follow
you around and see who you're hanging
out with because how Joe Biden behaves
in these clips with voters is not normal
let's look at the first one from Iowa
here Biden was asked about committing to
phase out fossil fuels and look at how
Joe Biden starts poking this guy in the
chest and getting aggressive with them
[Music]
[Music]
this is not normal and as we look at the
clip again this time without audio you
see that the guy he's talking to has
this sort of uncomfortable smile on his
face because he recognizes Joe Biden's
behavior is abnormal Joe Biden's staffer
or handler there that's a voice we've
gotten to know well on the campaign
trail as she's often trying to get
people to move on and get Joe Biden away
from people she starts saying move on
you know get it get it get a move on
when Joe Biden starts getting irritated
with the voter here's another example of
this this one was when Biden was asked
about some of his views on fossil fuels
this was at a Biden event and a guy
showed up the guy had critical questions
tough questions but they are reasonable
questions and again Biden gets in the
guy's face gets really close to the guy
starts poking the guy in the chest
eventually tells the guy find someone
else to vote for go vote for someone
else and you again hear that same
handlers say thank you so much trying to
end it but Biden just insists on talking
and pokes the guy and then kind of holds
on to the guys open coat strange
behavior take a look why is it well then
you want to replace these gas lines
that's not gonna work we can't we got to
stop building and replacing pipeline
this is not about would I vote for Biden
over Trump of course I would vote for
Biden over Trump this is not about
anything other than something about the
gleam in Joe Biden's eye when he starts
poking voters and treating them like
this is extremely odd and again to
people who saw me talk about this
briefly on stream and said David you're
a beta this is not aggressive behavior
this is how men interact when they have
conversations are you telling me this is
how you are interacting with people in
your everyday life people you know
friends family coworkers I don't have
anyone around me who number one treats
people this way or number two would
allow themselves to be treated this way
so if you watch these videos and this
strikes you as the normal interactions
of adults who are talking I want to hear
from you because maybe it's me in you
know my [ __ ] liberal northeastern city
as many of our viewers like to say but
this is not normal behavior that I've
observed between adults anywhere this is
the type of behavior I see between drunk
adults on the Las Vegas Strip shortly
before they get into a fistfight right
that's what it reminds me of let me know
what you think we'll have a couple of
these clips on our Instagram page at
david pakman show while you're there
follow me on instagram at david cat
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the david
pakman show it is great to have back
with us today rob Larson who is a
professor of economics and also author
of the book bit tyrants the political
economy of Silicon Valley Rob great to
have you on thanks Dave great to be here
so when I was on the Joe Rogan program a
few months ago we had this exchange
where he started talking about how of
course a company like Google is a
liberal company and it was an
interesting conversation because it
seemed that what he was talking about
was you know does Google have a policy
about anti-trans bullying and that type
of thing and I pointed out listen Google
is a company that is advocating for less
regulation is advocating for at a
financial level against some of the
antitrust interests that the people may
have and may want to have exercised
through their government and so if they
you know have an internal policy where
you can't misgender people that's not
really making them a liberal company
when you consider the sort of broader
circumstances of where they are in the
world of regulation and not paying taxes
and so on and so forth what is the right
way that we should sort of think about
the political orientation of these big
tech companies that often have a sort of
progressive ish seeming public side but
behind the scenes are really very
similar to you know an oil company or
whatever else the case may be yeah right
on
well that's you know very true these
companies definitely do affect a very
you know whoa very Pro diversity sort of
public posture but to me I think based
on my research there what right way to
sort of frame this issue is to look at
it from a point of view of what the
company wants and then what like the
workforce wants if you sort of dig into
it a lot of the time when people talk
about
how these companies are liberal and
they're so on the left it sounds goofy
because these are after all publicly
traded corporations whose stock is held
by the wealthier households of our
society and big financial institutions
how could they be leftist and
anti-capitalist I think a lot of the
confusion is people look at what yeah
the workforce is saying and then impute
that to the company like well the
company must be liberal then but of
course as we've seen just in the last
several months we've had a couple of
fairly significant labor actions against
Google where the workforce various
components of its enormous workforce are
doing walkouts and going on small
strikes and doing independent organizing
and just lately I mean I think maybe the
ultimate rebuttal to claims these
companies are liberal it's just lately
Google has been retaining the same
classic union-busting you know anti
labor organization law firms that
Walmart and Microsoft have been hiring
for years you know and especially to
when you look at the interface with
public policy in the face of all these
new investigations that big tech
including Google are subject to what
they call the tech lash you know so
could the congressional investigations
the FTC and Justice Department of probes
and the state attorneys general as well
Google is now one of the biggest
lobbying firms in Washington spending
many million a year more than all of its
tech peers more than Amazon even on
lobbying the government of course they
play a big role in election financing
both directly and through their packs so
to me what I would just suggest to folks
like mr. Rogan is it's really worth
taking a small amount of time to
differentiate between what the labor
force is pushing for and what the
company wants and then yes like policies
letters say for example diversity
oriented for a richer representative
staff is in like protecting the rights
of trans workers versus like the real
money aspect of the equation which the
firms are most interested in all the
lobbying and maintenance of their
monopolies Google got the FTC to just
stop investigating investigating it
during the Obama years like that's where
these bodies are buried one of the big
differences between tech companies and a
lot of other companies is that there's
often some kind of
almost like a fairy tale a romanticized
story about the origins of the company
you know Mark Zuckerberg invented it and
it has been his Harvard dorm room
invented Facebook Jeff Bezos was in some
job he hated and you know had the idea
to start Amazon and whatever else you
don't see that with a lot of other types
of companies that many of us interact
with regularly whether they be car
companies of you know airline companies
or whatever the case may be I'm curious
whether part of that is because a lot of
those other companies have just been
around much longer so the story of their
creation seems less relevant because
it's further away or is there something
more has there been a concerted effort
to keep the mystique through these sort
of fairy tale origin stories yeah
that's a great question I think we have
pretty much those are the two dynamics
if you look at all of our great
blue-chip fortune 500 companies
including your classic old accompany
giants you know GM and so on or Ford
knew IBM they all have this very folksy
yes small business I developed this
company in my mom's basement in the
depression sort of origin mystique it's
true these companies are all much
younger of course you know several of
them are only 10 20 years old so their
origin story is more recent and
therefore more foregrounded but also
just because of the information based
nature of these products there's a
little bit more of a but how did you get
the great idea for this company because
since their information base the idea
for their platforms and for their
services is kind of more of the core of
the whole business than it is if you're
manufacturing light bulbs and stuff so
it's true like there really is that
small business started in a garage
mystique but of course as I look at in
one of the chapters of the book the
firm's very of course but very typically
their origins in terms of their
technology comes straight from the
public sector so Google again it's a
classic case we'll talk about you know
Sir Jay and pate Sergey Brin and Larry
Page they had the idea to start the firm
as this great idea and they built all
these great businesses sense I was just
want to remind people Google's original
web address wasn't google.com it was
Google dot stanford.edu
because
develop that at Stanford research labs
in their computer science program one of
the great publicly funded research
university campuses in the United States
where you've got stable funding and you
are allowed to indulge your intellectual
curiosity and think freely about what
would make a good search engine or what
we make a good social networking system
in the marketplace you're under
near-term pressures for profitability to
get your stock price up and keep Wall
Street happy with you in the academic
world you're free to take your time and
of course the internet itself after all
was originally developed by DARPA you
know the Pentagon's research arm along
with the university system and in the
book I just go through Amazon Facebook
Google and the internet and the hardware
itself like the stuff in your smartphone
you know almost all of that technology
comes from one or another public sector
research institution or at least through
heavy public funding which again
insulates you from that short-term
market pressure so to me the story of
the origins of these firms is one of the
juiciest phony aspects about them well
so to stick with that a little bit can
you talk a little bit about what sort of
regulatory or financial incentives also
existed that allowed these companies to
do what they did and to grow as quickly
as they did I mean certainly at a base
level people increasingly dependent on
the internet and more and more of
day-to-day society being run through the
internet is a huge boon to a company
that exists on mobile phones and on the
internet for sure but in terms of
regulation tax breaks etc what else was
done that allowed these companies to
grow so quickly at the start for sure
well the very loose regulatory framework
is an important part of this story all
through the era when the internet and
internet-based services were becoming
more popularized like in the I'm old
enough to remember in the 90s when the
internet came to town and you could go
to some library campuses and look up
other card catalogues like at that time
it was a bipartisan view that what you
don't want to do is regulate the
internet or online industries because
that's going to impose new costs on them
or limit their you know their innovation
and their creativity and for the longest
time like what
through the Bush years into into the
Obama years that was something that was
more or less bipartisan we don't want to
regulate the net it's growing it's
giving us all these fun free services
and so on now of course as these firms
have become so important and as you say
it's we're so reliant on them and we
start seeing their power in elections in
our society and the way that we do with
everything through our phones people are
a lot more interested in putting some
leashes on their behavior and on their
power but to me the real issue with
having had such a loose regulatory
framework for so long for big tech is
what I talked about in the first chapter
of the book these are markets that are
subject to what we call network effects
in economics and network effect is just
something that applies to certain
markets where an information based
product is at play and the big thing
there is that with those sort of markets
the service gains value the more people
use it so like a telephone you know as
more people get on the phone network
your telephone gets a little bit more
valuable to you cuz there's more and
more people you can potentially call
well the same network effects apply to
companies like Facebook you want to be
on the network that has all your friends
on it not on the one that has no one on
it and Google search even there's more
people to do Google searches day in and
day out there are algorithms keep
learning from that and the more search
searches that are done the stronger
their algorithm and search processes
become so the thing about network
effects is there a strong incentive that
leads to monopolization or maybe having
two or three very dominant firms in a
market and that is what we see in big
tech from Facebook's
and instagrams you know oligopoly - you
know Google's mobile search monopoly -
YouTube there's a long list but it's all
these straight economic aspects to it so
there was a big deal made when Amazon
basically after being shamed by Bernie
Sanders decided that they were going to
start paying everybody 15 bucks an hour
and the end result I thought was great
of course it was a calculation for
Amazon that there was going to be a PR
benefit more than likely that in the
long term would exceed the additional
cost to them of paying the 15 bucks an
hour but let's ignore that for a second
let's imagine that it worked in that an
elected official shamed a company and
they made the
decision when Donald Trump between being
elected and inaugurated went to I
believe it was Indiana or Iowa Indiana
and announced that he struck a deal with
carrier Air Conditioner that they were
going to keep their factory open in
Indiana and what he basically did was
just give him money right there was a
plan where carrier decided we're leaving
and Trump came in and said hey here's
some money if you stay my criticism at
the time was this is not a scalable
economic policy this is saying hey I
found a company that has already made a
business decision I'm changing the
calculus by giving them some cash and of
course in the end that money was used to
start automating away those jobs anyway
half of the workforce still went to
Mexico it was a disaster there's not
that much of a difference in a sense
between Trump giving money to carrier to
get them to stay and Bernie pressuring
one company to pay 15 bucks an hour now
of course the the one that Bernie did is
working out much better in terms of is
its results but my question is about the
scalability of policy when it comes to
these things we can't really be relying
on elected officials to be making
one-off deals can we I mean it seems to
me that we need something systemic to be
done about regulation incentives job
creation whatever the case may be oh
absolutely
and I think even like across you know
the wide spectrum of opinions about big
tech I think that that is sort of
recognized so again whether you're
suspicious of big tech from a more left
or a more conservative point of view I
think broadly its recognized what you
need yeah it's a set of stable rules
that are uniform from one company to
another
yeah and stable across time you can't
just be piecemeal threatening or
throwing cash at these firms but again
what it sort of comes back to though is
the power of these firms like most
companies couldn't get all of America's
cities to debase themselves and beg for
a second headquarters but Amazon
absolutely was able to do that and it
was quite a spectacle and they ended up
splitting the investment and walking
away from New York and then of course
putting tens of thousands of jobs there
anyway without millions of dollars in
cash
which kind of shows perhaps the lack of
necessity for these huge subsidy and
incentive packages but hopefully with
these new investigations we have coming
down at the national level and indeed
the international level of these big
tech firms and we do have the FTC and
the Justice Department here and overseas
like the strongest regulations so far
that any of these firms are subject to
is all emanating from the European Union
from privacy to data storage to the
right to be forgotten it's interesting
and of course to talk about it in the
book a bit because the difference in
these regulatory conditions plus it does
end up mattering that all of these big
tech platform companies and their
monopolies or semi monopolies they are
all American and the European Union is
used to being partially dominated by
American firms you know from IBM to coke
but they're a little more willing to
regulate firms that are out of state
despite a real political presence that
those firms have overseas to but I think
a new rules based approach is very
reasonable especially one that limits
the power of these firms again we have a
fairly long record now of all of these
firms once network effects builds up
their market power from Microsoft all
the way to Google and Facebook they
aren't shy about using it to crush
competitors and destroy rivals I
mentioned this in the book there's just
a piece of Wall Street Journal reporting
about Facebook and they didn't seem to
be using this word ironically but they
mentioned that Facebook has a whole
little division in the company whose job
is to monitor startups you know new
small web-based firms that might
potentially compete with Facebook or one
of its other apps like Instagram or
messenger and there they try to buy up
that firm at a very early stage when
they can buy for just a million bucks
from some founder in their garage or
crush it or go after it legally in some
other way and the way the journal
described it was Facebook is out to
disrupt any potential challengers which
is kind of funny because of course all
these firms talked about is how we're
disruptors and we're breaking up that
inefficient old economy now that they're
the economy and the five biggest
companies in the u.s. are all these tech
platforms now which is unheard of
they try to disrupt and you know put
control over their upstarts and small
competitors too so I think rules
Wayne in these firms power or even go
further and putting the workforce more
in charge or in that way potentially
partially socializing the platforms to
me those are the things we should look
at things that address the firm's market
power no question about that we've been
speaking with Rob Larsen who's a
professor of economics the book is
called bit tyrants the political economy
of Silicon Valley we are linking to the
book definitely check it out Rob always
a pleasure having you on thanks Dave my
pleasure the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
in today's disgusting but totally
unsurprising news Donald Trump allegedly
referred to MSNBC reporter Katie Tours
transgender mom as a [ __ ] with a [ __ ]
dad those are the president's alleged
words so I'm allowed to save him this is
from a new book called sinking in the
swamp by Lachlan Marquis and a so win
sub sang Katie tour is the daughter of
Zoey tour
you might remember Zoey tour from the OJ
Simpson low-speed helicopter car chase
in that white Bronco in 1994 if you were
around then Zoey tour doesn't like Trump
and Zoey tour is a trans woman and the
book alleges that Donald Trump makes
horrible comments about women all the
time
he called a megan mccain the daughter of
the late senator john mccain dumber than
her father pointed out that she's been
getting fatter after she said things on
the view that trump didn't like this
actually started with trump getting into
it with katie tour herself when he was
running for president writing off her
questions sometimes during interviews
when he didn't want to answer one of her
questions he would say oh give me a
break next question katie very very
condescending he started calling her
little katie started calling her a
third-rate journalist all of that stuff
and once when she tried to follow up a
question with Trump he simply said be
quiet
then of course we get to these latest
allegations that Trump referred to Katie
tore privately as again a [ __ ] with a
[ __ ] dad referring to Katie Tours
transgender mom this is the president
now he will have defenders no matter
what he says and lots of people probably
agree with him there's a lot of people
in this country I don't know if it's you
know fifteen percent seventeen percent
that are extremely anti-trans and while
they probably would never be willing to
say what Donald Trump is accused of
saying they aren't gonna get too upset
about hearing that Donald Trump said it
that's one group there's also people who
don't necessarily even agree with Trump
attacking trans people but they do
generally want things to sort of go back
to the way they imagined things were in
the 1950s and they see treating trans
people respectfully
something that's not quite in line with
their 1950s ideal so they're not really
gonna get bent out of shape about
attacking trans people but they're not
going to go and do it themselves and
then of course remember first lady
Milani as Trump's big initiative was
going to be ending bullying fighting
bullying and her husband is one of the
biggest bullies of all sorts of
different groups of people based on
their identity that we know of I wish it
weren't the case but too many people
either like comments like these or
they're just indifferent as long as
Trump won't let Mexicans in the country
right or whatever their priority is it's
one of those areas where we just need to
change the dialogue completely a
different president could do that we
talked about lots of the things that
would take a long time to change and
Trump didn't create racism Trump didn't
create xenophobia or anti trans bias or
anti-semitism but when he says things
like this when he doesn't do anything
about the coalescing and growing
extremist movements he makes the people
who are into those ideologies emboldened
and more comfortable publicly displaying
their beliefs
if Trump leaves the White House in a
year that's not going to change the
views of these extremists but it might
put them back at least in a little bit
of a more hidden position in society
where they might think twice about going
public with these views and then over
time hopefully those views will continue
to dissipate or age out as we like to
say we can hope imagine being Katy tour
and finding out that the president
referred to a parent of yours in this
way it's almost inconceivable or at
least it would have been in 2015 but
this is 2020 United States and this
story barely makes headlines in the
midst of everything else that's going on
really really shocking stuff an
incredible thing happened yesterday
which is that the david pakman show
YouTube channel reached an extraordinary
milestone 800,000 subscribers that's an
eighth followed by five zeroes we have
the video it happened live on last
night's Iowa caucus stream let's take a
look at the big moment buckle in folk
we are very very close here we have
reached 800,000 subscribers
amazing and I don't know why but this
has not updated how lame is that it
seems to be broken
it's stuck at 799 can you imagine
oh there it is amazing incredible I hope
someone records that please clip that
please send it to me I want to post that
to my Instagram page or whatever please
email me that we did it he as you can
see a riveting and very very exciting
moment but in all seriousness thank you
thank you to the 800 now getting close
to 800 and 1000 of you check out a graph
of our subscribers that I put together
today I have some interesting little
factoids for you we've been building the
YouTube channel for a long time I went
back and looked our first month on
YouTube we had four subscribers I don't
mean that we gained four subscribers a
day after our entire first month on
YouTube we had four subscribers our
entire second year on YouTube we gained
thirty-two hundred subscribers an entire
year 3,200 subscribers just during
yesterday's livestream of the Iowa
caucuses we gained about 600 subscribers
in a three hour stream and we reached
this amazing milestone of eight hundred
thousand so thank you so much the next
goal of course is a million will
probably do something little for nine
hundred thousand but 1 million is really
that nice round number now this is funny
weeks ago I started looking at the
numbers we were in Jan you know first
week of January second week of January I
was looking at the numbers I was looking
at the calendar and I was thinking we
might be able to do eight hundred
thousand by my birthday which was on
Sunday February second and as we were
getting closer we were ten days away we
were five days away I looked and still
February 2nd seemed viable and we missed
it but my calculation was only off by
like 22 hours the new goal is 1 million
by Election Day ok 1 million by November
3rd 2020 it is very hard to predict with
much precision because so many factors
can affect this right now on socialblade
which tracks this data
it looks like we're on track to hit a
million subscribers sometime between
October 12 and December so we might
clear a million three weeks before the
election we might miss it by six weeks
it could end up getting pushed into 2021
depending on what happens now as we
close in I will fine-tune the numbers
but the goal which would be so huge for
the progressive movement to have another
show enter this category in the millions
along with TYT The Young Turks it would
be huge to do it before the 2020
election I'll keep you posted but as of
right now it's possible it's possible
and thank you to the more than 800,000
of you that are currently subscribed to
our YouTube channel really feels great
to have accomplished this we have a
voicemail number the number is two one
nine to david p this voicemail doesn't
feel so good to take a listen to what
this person has to say the david you're
a liberal hack and trump 2020 trump's
gonna win nobody cares about you and
your live on this the reality of the
situation is you're just like fox news
where you love to criticize just because
they love Trump but you love Bernie so I
don't see the difference
and I think you should be arrested for
spreading false information and also if
this was Soviet Russia you'd have a bull
in your [ __ ] head
well now I I do under false
misinformation is that a double negative
does that mean we're spreading just
information true information fun
misinformation would not be accurate if
it's false misinformation maybe it is
good and the person doesn't realize it
in any case that's what we are fighting
right so as a reminder you're not going
to convince that person to vote for
anybody other than Trump so don't bother
don't waste your time on it and these I
play these voicemails for you number one
just to let you know about the level of
vitriol that exists out there but number
two because these are illustrations that
we can't win we it's not a viable
strategy to say let's all go out and
convince people like that dude not to
vote for Trump it's not going to happen
the focus needs to be get out the vote
prevent voter suppression prevent a
toxic destructive primary that will
actually do damage to the opportunity to
remove Donald Trump that is the
find the half of the country that
doesn't vote and talk to the people who
agree with us and make sure that they go
out and vote because the conversation
with that guy is a dead end might as
well run a motorcycle directly into a
brick wall you're not going to get
anything accomplished the focus has to
be a different one we have a great bonus
show for you today we will talk about
DNC members who are discussing possible
rule changes at the convention to
potentially deny Bernie Sanders the
nomination if it were to come to it
secondly even insured adults who have
health insurance are increasingly going
to primary care less and less often
because of the out-of-pocket costs these
are folks with insurance we will talk
about that we will also talk about the
news shocking in the media world that
right-wing radio host Rush Limbaugh says
he has advanced lung cancer immediately
will be missing a lot of his show
undergoing treatment we will discuss
that and much more on today's bonus show
get access instantly by becoming a
member at join pakman.com or by becoming
a patron at the $5 or greater level at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]